[Musik]
ja willkommen bei einer neuen sendung
von 4cast hier auf dem podcast das
heutige thema ist ästhetik alu jörg
hallo marcel also ästhetik ist ja eine
viel besprochenes thema wie hängt das
mit digitalität zusammen wäre natürlich
jetzt die frage als ansagen als als
startpunkt hast du von emotionen
gesprochen von von verein nehmen oder
von 1 geschlungen werden genau version
ist ein ganz zentraler begriff den gibt
es natürlich schon lange vor der
erfindung von computerspielen oder von
überhaupt digitalen strukturen in
version bedeutet einfach einbezogen
werden oder genauer gesagt sogar
eintauchen
also wie wenn man in so ein mehr oder
ein swimmingpool eintaucht so taucht man
ein in bestimmten medien zb auch in
bestimmte geschichten wenn man ein buch
liest und von der geschichte so
hingerissen ist und in dieser logik
denkt und fasst die geschichte dann für
die wirklichkeit hält dann ist man
wirklich hat ist man eingetaucht in
diese in diese ästhetik und das meint
eigentlich immersion und immersion ist
deswegen für die digitalisierung die
digitalität zentrale weil sich hier
viele neue möglichkeiten einer immersion
bieten
und darauf können wir gleich noch ein
bisschen näher zu sprechen kommen ja
okay also du meinst das gemeint ist dass
man eintaucht und dass diese ästhetik
teil der wirklichkeit wird
ich frage mich jetzt warum ist denn
ästhetik sonst nicht teil meiner
wirklichkeit weil wenn ich durch straßen
geh oder in einer ausstellung mit
designobjekten ich bin ja umgeben von
ästhetik das ist ja meine realität in
der ich mich bewege man mein handy
einmal andere smartphone ist auch ein
ästhetisches objekt also ich eben wir
fangen ganz viele punkte ein
inwiefern unterscheidet sich das jetzt
bei computerspielen oder so also ich
sagte ja computerspiele sind für mich
das paradigma einer ästhetik der
digitalität also wenn wir über die neuen
formen von ästhetik sprechen wollen
deshalb die frage gibt es überhaupt
durch die digitalisierung
neue formen der ästhetik ich glaube ja
und wenn wir das glauben dann müssen wir
besonders auf das phänomen der
computerspiele acht jetzt fragt dass du
ihr unterscheidet sich denn so ein
computerspiel von anderen ästhetischen
formen
nehmen wir als beispiel den kinofilm ich
sitze in einem kino und betrachte die
leinwand und dieser kinofilm der strömt
auf mich ästhetisch heißt ja auch
wahrnehmbar also heißt es ist griechisch
ist die wahrnehmung der kinofilm wird
durch meine augen wahrgenommen durch die
ohren wird er wahrgenommen und
vielleicht nur durch was anderes nur
aber vor allem eben durch den zähen den
hörsinn und wenn ich mir so einen
kinofilm anschaut dann bin ich
eigentlich nur ein passiver rezipient
eine passiven rezipienten ich sitze im
stuhl ist vielleicht ein bisschen
popcorn und der strömte auf mich eine
medial fall bin ich eben nicht mehr nur
passiv sondern ich imaginäre mich da
hinein das kann auch gut durchaus
vorkommen im kinofilm also wie beim buch
man würde sie sich vorstellen man ist
jetzt tatsächlich in der welt das meinst
du genau also man ist so von dieser
geschichte gefesselt man identifiziert
sich mit bestimmten personen
man fühlt dass mit das ist immer
emotionen und jetzt ist die frage was
ist jetzt bei computerspielen neue
computerspiele sind doch sagt man häufig
nur einen simulationen zum beispiel auch
nur gut hier kommt eben der
entscheidende faktoren spielt das wie es
bei computerspielen mit avataren zu tun
zb mit spielfiguren
das haben im kino nicht im kino gibt es
figuren aber die steuere ich nicht die
werden vom regisseur von der regisseurin
gesteuert ich selbst kann bei
computerspielen die figur steuern und
zwar zum beispiel auf 2d super mario
oder commander keen da mache ich oben
rechts ein link geradezu der besprechung
dieses spiels da habe ich ein avatar den
ich sagen aus der dritten person
betrachte er oder sie steuere ich jetzt
gibt es aber auch computerspiele die aus
der ersten person
man macht sich selber sein charakter
meinte daheim bleiben
damit meine ich ego-shooter genau und es
gibt aber auch noch wie du richtig sagst
einen zusätzlichen punkt wo du den
charakter selbst schaffst zb in
rollenspielen online-rollenspielen
diablo oder sowas
und das wird mir jetzt eben zum
entscheidenen punkt also erst einmal
kann vielmehr interagieren noch immer
den avatar selbst steuert man
identifiziert sich mit ihm und man
bestimmt selbst welche wendung dieses
spiel diese ästhetik nimmt an und jetzt
kommt das thema online rollenspiel das
wird nochmal eine stufe intensiver weil
wir da in dem wir online interagieren
mit anderen subjekten gegeneinander
antreten
eine neue sozial- und theologie
entwickeln das bedeutet wir bewegen uns
nicht mehr auf der ebene der simulation
wir tun nicht mehr so als ob wir
irgendwas interpretierten sondern wir
tun es wirklich zum beispiel ministern
um wertgegenstände in world of warcraft
geht besonders seltene gegenstände in
diesem spiel
die haben realen wert von wenigen euro
ist bis tausende von euros stichwort
runescape blaue party hoch oben rechts
martin link rein da sieht man ganz klar
dass die ästhetik nicht mehr nur
simulatoren gehalt hat der blaue patriot
ist keine simulation er ähnelt
vielleicht einem wirklichen hut aber er
geht darin nicht auf in seiner funktion
simuliert nicht nur seine hat eine
funktion die durch seine zu nutzen im
spiel definiert wird durch seine
seltenheit und durch die inter subjektiv
einigkeit darüber wie ich ihn wert er
aufgrund seiner seltenheit hat und der
wert ist ziemlich genau 1700 dollar
also ist mir sei es einleuchtend der mit
einem beispiel das sogenannte hass der
unterschied zwischen simulation und
virtuelle könntest du ganz kurz noch mal
bei dieser matrix situation von dem film
matrix
das ist ja so dass das
die in einer scheinwelt leben und es
gibt diesen teuscher dimon
wo würdest du da wie wird das
beschreiben ist das eine simulation in
der sie leben ist virtuell virtualität
oder oder was ganz anderes
die nase der unterschied zwischen
simulation und virtuelle realität das
ist so die die opposition und ist ein
gutes beispiel was du da bringst von
matrix weil man ja eigentlich sagen
würde das ist eine simulation da sind
diese figuren die protagonisten sitzen
zu den sesseln und zucken so ein
bisschen wenn sie da eben diese
simulation durchmachen aber wie man ja
der geschichte sieht ist das was ich in
dieser vermeintlichen simulation
abspielt entscheidend also hier werden
handlungen vollzogen
häufig auch im interview aktiven raum
also selbst wenn es eine virtuelle
umgebung ist treten hier mehrere freie
subjekte in dieser virtuellen umgebung
gegen dann wie eben auch einem
computerspiel rollenspiel also matrix
wäre im grunde genommen so verstanden
ein online rollenspiel in das man eben
ganz auf gesuchen wird ja und
unfreiwillig richtig aber indem man eben
doch frei wer also wenn man einmal drin
ist in den spielen in der matrix dann
muss man frei sich halt macht ja neo
auch der entscheidet ja durchaus der
überlegt so ein bisschen und da wird ja
auch zum hält dadurch dass er frei
agiert und man könnte es wirklich als
eine höhere stufe eines online
rollenspiels ansehen weil man in der
matrix eben ganz drin ist und auch eben
physikalisch sofort feedback bekommt und
eine direkte rückmeldung bekommt und
eben ganz involviert ist dass wir die
maximale form der immersion die dann
eben in eine form von virtueller
realität überführt wird
ok und also du hast es ziemlich
einleuchtend erklärt warum irgendwie
ästhetik vor allem in computerspielen
in meiner eigenen wirklichkeit dann
aufgeht also ist sie dazu etwas realem
inwiefern ist es jetzt in der welt in
der wir uns bewegen der wir hier vor dem
mikro sitzen inwiefern ist es nicht
möglich hier dass das habe ich noch
nicht ganz verstanden wo ist die
trennung warum ist das ästhetische jetzt
in diesem fall dass ich vor dem mikro
bin und dieses die auch im design objekt
dass ich das anschauen wie ein wenig
getrennt von dieser ästhetik weil das
hat er auch ein wert ich kann das auch
verkaufen
ich kann das ich kann interagieren sind
ja gut ich würde sagen so ein mikrofon
ist eben nicht in erster linien
ästhetischer gegenstand ein mikrofon hat
natürlich wie alle gegenstände die wir
nutzen immer eine ästhetische qualität
aber in erster linie ist ein mikrofon
ein instrument und es geht nicht in
seinem ästhetischen nutzen auf gut diese
mikrofon ist von rohde
das hat natürlich dementsprechende gute
ästhetik klar aber ich würde es nicht
als ästhetischen gegenstand anziehen
sind als ein reines instrument
funktionaler gegenstand und ästhetik
kommt dann ins spiel wenn ich eben
gerade nicht mehr etwas als mittel zum
zweck ansehe
immanuel kants sagt schönheit und
ästhetik ist interesse loses
wohlgefallen
da gefällt mir einen gegenstand als
solcher und nicht nur als mittel zum
zweck dieses mikrofon gefällt mir nur
insofern eigentlich als ich es gut
gebrauchen kann als es jetzt hier diese
aufnahme auch nicht gut macht ja anders
ist es mit einem kunstwerk was ich ins
museum beobachte genau so wäre es
übrigens wenn ich dieses mikrofon in
einem museum stellen würde
und aus der steckdose aus stecken würde
in die mitte eines museums in einem
glaskasten
dann wäre dieses mikrofon nicht mehr als
instrument sichtbar in diesem als pace
diesem raum der kunst sind es wäre eben
nur reduziert auf seine ästhetische form
das heißt je nachdem wie wir die dinge
perspektiven betrachten können wir aus
einem instrumentellen gegenstand auch in
ästhetischen gegenstand machen aber
solange wir jetzt hier vor diesem
mikrofon sitzen ist es eben kein
ästhetischer gegenstand
nutzen den wir daraus ziehen können aus
der beobachtung dass computerspiele oder
andere phänomene der digitalität in den
dimensionen stattfindet und in denen es
tätig so etwas also in dinge in ihrem
ästhetischen wert primär zur funktion
treten und aufgehen können wir was
daraus ziehen durch diese erkenntnis ist
es nicht hilfreich ist es ein ort an dem
wir das ausleben können was wir sonst
nicht ausleben können natürlich also ich
sag mal virtuelle realitäten oder auch
digitale form der ästhetik vor allem
eben computerspiele erlauben es uns uns
viel freier zu bewegen und eben nicht
nur seine rezipienten perspektive
einzunehmen wie wir es im kino tun
sondern wir bewegen uns an der grenze
von verschiedenen sphären zwischen
realität und ästhetik wir spielen mit
dieser grenze und das finde ich ganz
spannend also philosophisch nicht nur
sondern auch eben ja in der
alltagsrealität dass wir sehen wieder
realitäten ineinander übergehen und die
grenzen immer schwimmender werden und
das finde ich ziemlich spannend das
aktiv zu reflektieren und im alltag zu
praktizieren
vielen dank das war jetzt unsere folge
zu ist tätig die nächste wird dann über
ethik gehen und ja das dann ja wieder
[Musik]